esto es el segundo año que los
ucranianos conmemoran la Pascua ortodoxa
después de la invasión rusa en febrero
24 del año pasado
está Pascua ortodoxa se celebra en el
calendario juliano que generalmente es
días después de la paz
católica la cristiana que celebramos la
mayoría de creyentes católicos la semana
pasada y Es bien interesante porque una
sociedad como lo ucraniana que es
bastante creyente ellos lo celebran en
uno de sus días más especiales con los
tradicionales huevos que han pintado los
niños y también con un pan especial las
familias las hemos visto caminando esta
mañana en la calle con los niños con
estos elementos tradicionales muchos de
ellos llevan su ropa tradicional
ucraniana y en esta ceremonias como la
que vemos actualmente que se llevan a
cabo en varias de las muchas muchos
militares también caminan por la calle
muchos de los quienes prestan servicio y
están en los frentes de batalla en
Ucrania provienen de estas regiones del
oeste del país nosotros estamos esta
mañana en la ciudad de Leví Pero esto
igual se celebra en cada una de las
ciudades de Ucrania también a la espera
de lo que pueda suceder con esta llamada
contraofensiva que están esperando los
ucranianos para hacer retroceder a las
tropas rusas y también retomar
territorios ocupados esto En un momento
en el que Rusia ha vuelto a lanzar
ataques especialmente
en la ciudad de eslobians que el 14 de
abril donde morían 11 personas entre
ellos un niño de 2 años